pues bueno en esta ocasión me voy a
tomar la siguiente integral esta
integral está un poco más complicada que
todas las que hemos visto pero va a
estar muy entretenido resolverlo y me
queda la integral de x cúbica por la
raíz de 9 - x cuadrada diferencial de x
y lo primero que se nos puede ocurrir es
intentar resolver esto por sustituciones
y cuando métrica debido a que tenemos
adentro de la raíz un 9 - x cuadrada que
es lo mismo que 3 al cuadrado menos x
cuadrada ya habíamos dicho en el vídeo
pasado que todo lo que tenía la forma de
a cuadrada - x cuadrada salía de una
manera muy sencilla si hacíamos una
sustitución trigonométricas que
sustitución trigonométricas pues
decíamos que x era igual a a veces el
seno de teta
por lo tanto sustituyendo a x me
quedaría que esto es lo mismo que a
cuadrada menos a cuadrada seno cuadrado
de teta o dicho de otra manera esto es
lo mismo que a cuadrada que multiplica a
uno menos seno cuadrado de teta y uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta era el
coseno cuadrado de 30 por lo tanto para
esto nos sirve hacer este cambio de
variable así que vamos a trabajar con él
ya que nos conviene tomar
bueno x va a ser tres veces el seno de
teta es decir la raíz de nueve que
multiplica al seno de teta y bueno si ya
tenemos a equis de una vez sería bueno
calcular la diferencia de x la
diferencial de x va a ser igual a la
derivada de tres veces el seno de teta
con respecto a teta y de una vez lo
vamos a escribir en su forma diferencial
por lo tanto despejando a de x me va a
quedar lo siguiente tres veces el coche
no beteta diferencial de teta tres veces
el coche no detectan diferencia del dt
está muy bien ya tenemos a x ya tenemos
a de x es muy buen momento para empezar
a sustituir en esta integral por lo
tanto que voy a obtener voy a agarrar y
cambiar de color y ahora tengo la
integral de x cúbica pero x es lo mismo
que tres veces el seno de teta por lo
tanto me queda 3 al cubo que es 27 x
seno cúbico de teta vamos a hacerlo muy
colorido para que no nos vayamos
perdiendo en el camino de color azul me
queda 3 al cubo que es 27 por el seno
cúbico de teta y después tengo esta raíz
y para esto me voy a tomar el color
anaranjado entonces tengo estos de aquí
aquí es la raíz de 9 - x cuadrada es
decir de 9 menos nueve veces el seno
cuadrado de teta porque x es tres veces
el 69 teta nueve menos nueve veces el
seno de teta todo esto dentro de la raíz
y después por la diferencial de x pero
la diferencial de x ya la calculamos es
esto que tenemos aquí con un nuevo color
esto de aquí es lo mismo que todo esto
que acabamos de calcular y me queda que
multiplica a tres veces el coste no de
teta diferencial de teta muy bien y
ahora es momento de simplificar todo
esto pero antes de simplificar toda esta
expresión lo que quiero hacer es qué va
a pasar con esta raíz entonces
simplifiquemos lo que tenemos adentro de
la raíz me queda 9 factor izado que
multiplica a 1 - el seno cuadrado de
teta y esto lo mismo que 9 que
multiplica al coseno cuadrado de teta
recuerden que uno menos el seno cuadrado
del tema es el coseno cuadrado de teta y
en el vídeo pasado vimos que el coche no
cuadrado de teta en este caso es siempre
positivo por lo tanto no es necesario
poner el valor absoluto y esto me va a
quedar simple y sencillamente tres veces
el coseno de teta
ok entonces esto era la simplificación
de esta raíz y me queda simple y
sencillamente tres veces el coste no de
teta entonces ahora sí voy a simplificar
todo 27 por 3 es lo mismo que 81 y 81
por 3 es lo mismo que 3 por una que es 3
3 por 8 24 243 entonces afuera me queda
243 que multiplica al integral y ahora
si me queda el seno cúbico voy a tomar
otro color el seno cúbico de teta y
después me queda el coche no detecta que
multiplica el coste de 9 t tan
diferencial de teta eso es el coseno
cuadrado de teta diferencial de teta
todo esto ya lo simplifica y al final
tengo que poner la diferencia de teta
entonces todo esto multiplicado por de
teta y ahora tenemos una nueva integral
la cual parece que tiene solución con
una sustitución y sin embargo resolver
esta integral no es tan fácil tampoco es
una integral que salga de volada pero en
esta ocasión lo que quiero enseñarles es
cómo se pueden resolver también las
integrales de este estilo
estas son las integrales que tienen
potencias en las funciones
trigonométricas y más aún cuando tenemos
que una de estas dos funciones
trigonométricas tienen una potencia
impar y la otra parte entonces suena muy
lógico que esto lo podamos escribir de
la siguiente manera para poder resolver
este problema esto es lo mismo que 243
que multiplica a la integral del seno
cúbico pero el seno cúbico lo voy a
desmenuzar en dos partes primero me va a
quedarse en un cuadrado de teta y
después voy a poner otra vez el coseno
cuadrado de teta y al final voy a poner
el seno que me falta seno cuadrado para
el seno público me falta un seno y
entonces al final voy a poner el seno de
teta diferencial de teta quiero que
vayan viendo cómo resuelvo esta integral
para que ustedes no tengan problema
alguno cuando se topen este tipo de
integrales la idea es ahora escribir el
seno cuadrado de teta como una función
del coste no cuadrado de teta utilizando
la identidad trigonométricas lo que voy
a querer es escribir todo esta integral
con una función del coseno beteta para
poder hacer mi cambio de variable y
igual al coche no de teta y es que dese
cuenta que es justa esta idea tras la
que boyle voy a hacer
este cambio de variable en un futuro
entonces vamos a hacerlo me queda 243
veces la integral de uno menos coseno
cuadrado de teta esto es el seno
cuadrado de teta ya su vez esto
multiplica al coseno cuadrado de teta y
esto a su vez multiplica al 09 teta
diferencial de teta y tal vez te estés
preguntando para que todo este lío y
bueno es que la idea que hay detrás de
todo esto es que la derivada del coche
no de teta es casi el seno de teta y por
eso estoy separando el seno de teta para
ella tener una función del coste no de
teta y después tener la derivada del
coseno por lo tanto todo esto va a ser
la función que tiene que ver con el
coste no beteta y todo esto que está
aquí va a tener que ver con la derivada
del coste de teta es justo en este
momento cuando se me ocurre la idea de
que puedo usar un cambio de variable y
me cambio de variable como más o menos
les vengo comentando va a ser o igual al
coseno de teta y ya con esto vamos a ver
si salen bien las cuentas o es igual al
coche 9 teta y las diferencial de v es
igual al menos 69 teta diferencial de
teta qué es
si este que tenemos aquí lo único que me
falta es multiplicarlo por menos y se
aumenta un menos entonces también tengo
que poner este menos afuera de la
integral porque menos x menos me da más
entonces aquí ya tengo la diferencial de
eeuu y voy a sustituir a como el
concepto de teta y esto ya me va a
quedar mucho más sencillo de resolver
esto es lo mismo que menos 243 que
multiplica al integral de 1 - coseno
cuadrado de teta pero el cociente de
teta es su y por lo tanto se me queda
uno menos cuadrada que multiplica el
coseno cuadrado de teta es decir un
cuadrado y después que multiplica al
menos 100 9 teta diferencial de teta que
como tenemos aquí arriba esto es la
diferencia al de eeuu y esta integral ya
es muy sencilla de resolver es una
integral que sale en dos pasos realmente
trabaje todo esto para que me quede una
integral muy sencilla date cuenta que
resolver está integral es resolver o
integral de un polinomio de 1 es decir
vamos a utilizar la anti derivada de la
regla de la potencia y vamos a
resolverla esto me queda menos 243 de la
integral y ahora voy a distribuir lado
cuadrada me queda cuadrada menos 1 4a
todo esto diferencial de 1 lo único que
haciendo distribuirla o cuadrada o
cuadrada por 1 me queda un cuadrado o
cuadrada por un cuadrado me queda un
cuarto y todo esto que multiplica la
diferencia de 1 y esta integral ya sale
en un solo paso esto es lo mismo que
menos 243 de un pública entre 3 menos
quinta entre 5 que es la integral de
cuadrada y cuarta respectivamente y
después le sumamos una constante
integración y ahora se multiplicó todo
esto por el menos 243 lo único que va a
pasar es que el primero se va a volver
negativo y el segundo se va a volver
positivo por lo tanto voy a poner el 243
todavía factor izado me va a quedar 243
y el 243 va a multiplicar a un quinta
entre 5 ya esto le vamos a restar cúbica
entre 3 lo único que hice fue cambiar
los signos y después le sumamos la
constante integración y ya está ya está
en términos de 1 lo que voy a ver en el
siguiente vídeo es precisamente pasar
todo esto a términos de x y para eso voy
a tener que hacer la sustitución hacia
atrás varias veces recuerda que la x es
la variable original es decir el menú va
a hacer pasar términos de eeuu en
términos
y después términos de theta en términos
de x y así obtener la solución de esta
integral